and level from the supper sweet yet
again we are here in Austin for South by
Southwest and right now we have a new
interview for you because we have these
wonderful sponsors like El Tesoro
tequila thanks so much to them because
thanks to their support we get to talk
about movies like the girl on the third
floor and I'm so excited to be here for
a variety of reasons but I'm especially
excited because this guy is sitting
right next to me and we we met I think
at Sundance and not Sundance South by
Southwest years ago because you were
here with one of the many movies you had
produced so just to start here what is
it like having such a prolific producing
resume and then waking up one morning
and saying I'm gonna direct one now yes
yes it's like this where you basically
are wearing way too much is going on and
you're just gonna put your head down and
try to get through it no it's it's it's
really interesting it's given me a lot
more empathy for writers and directors
because you're you're you're on the
other side of that dynamic and and and
you're receiving rather than sort of
dictating stuff so I feel like the big
differences I'm a lot more nervous than
I normally am because you know you sort
of put yourself out there and I'm also
trying to get more sleep I'm like
professional don't worry we're gonna get
through this even with all the producing
experience on your resume is there
anything about jumping in as a director
that made you think like oh like I
didn't even realize how that was done no
I mean I've been fortunate to work with
so many talented directors that is
basically the best film school so really
just sort of trying to learn from them
and pay attention to the elements that
play in their success and avoiding the
stuff you know anything that was sort of
handicapping that so I think our shoot
you know there wasn't any unforeseen
things that were happening so it felt
pretty seamless that's what happens when
you've produced a lot of yeah I guess so
I'm curious about how
you got involved in this did a script
come your way were you seeking something
just like everything else in my life
just kind of fell from the sky I was
fortunate enough to have been
recommended by Bobcat Goldthwait which
is I don't know like a feather in my cap
like that's not something as you know
like an eight year old kid watching
police academy that you would ever think
would possibly happen in your life but
thankfully he did and somebody you know
a friend of a friend knew how to get
ahold of me
so that's how it works everybody it's
not what you know it's who you know and
they contacted me and I've been
contacted in the past about things you
know hey oh we really want to do this
project we want to do this movie so at
first I did kind of take it with a grain
of salt and then the names attached to
it you know you you can't not go oh wait
what with the first time I heard
Travis's name I was like the guy who
produced utero skis dune so without even
reading the script I was immediately
like I'm in like it can't be a bad
experience and then I was fortunate
enough to be blessed with this amazing
cast great people
I mean m'm from catering to makeup to
sound everybody on the set in the house
was exceptional to work with and that's
where I'm at in my life no [ __ ] you
know I'm fortunate that I can pick you
know and choose things and my one rule
is I'm not working with everybody that
sucks so you know you have the stamp of
approval up here everybody here is a
nice kind human being a nice time human
being and an absolutely crazy bloody
creepy movie because our viewers
probably do not know much about it I was
wondering if the cast could kind of just
do a little bit of a roll call and maybe
explain how your character fits in and
one thing that made that character
really enjoyable for you to play I guess
I'll start um yeah I I come in as
the handyman force is Travis by the way
my name is Travis yes Delgado to
differentiate for mr. Stevens here yeah
no I I just come in and and help and
sort of provide a comic relief to the
film to start and then from there it
kind of descends into this very dark
place that's an understatement
I don't know how much they should give
away well I do your best to not spoil
anything okay
well I had a lot of fun playing my
character because she is a real person
ask so I got to play with both worlds
like life and death so that was really
fun and god I had so much fun playing
this this character she's just a badass
you know I don't want to give anything
away but super super fun I had so much
fun playing playing with my cast mates
and playing with the girl on the third
floor I played on coke who may or may
not be a nice guy depending on your
point of view and I think that's what
makes us interesting obviously you have
to kind of come to your own conclusions
I think he's I think he's a lovable guy
you know and then you watch the movie
and you may or may not find out some
things as he tries to renovate this this
this old house tears out some some walls
and maybe some you know things from his
past kind of get torn out with it
but it's not your simple straightforward
good guy bad guy you know protagonist
antagonist sort of thing there's there's
levels and there's layers to it and that
is what I enjoyed the most about all
this my name is Trieste and I played Liz
Don's wife and I was terrified to do the
movie actually because I'm so scared of
horror films
like I am still afraid of Nightmare on
Elm Street when that I watched when I
was maybe like eight years old and I
still have nightmares like not that
often but twice a year so I was really
scared that I was gonna have nightmares
because this is a real haunted house
they bought this house and it's it's
like in the news in Chicago this house
is actually haunted so I was kind of
scared but then once you're there and
there's like a million people around and
Travis is there with his like notebook
and Phil's there like what the [ __ ] is
my line and then it's just like you're
making a movie general just like actors
doing their thing directors doing their
thing and then it's just a set but there
were creepy stories about the house like
did in the art department gals didn't
they have a bunch of because they were
there till 4:00 in the morning and
evidently like doorknobs were turning
which is what all the people in the news
said was happening doorknobs would turn
and like doors would open in this one
room in the house like it's based on a
real thing that and I'm like how do I
book a room in that house I can see it
all well we ain't bought that you do
they still own the house if you made
arrangements I would hands down sleep in
that house by myself there is a church
across the street so you can like
cleanse yourself yeah all of her makeup
and hair was in the church so we would
come out from night shoots like 5:00 in
the morning covered in all kinds of
things you know blood whatever and we'd
be like crossing the street and people
be like showing up to you know Sunday
school with like I was always way more
uncomfortable in the church so I tried
to scurry across the street to get into
the haunted house so I was like ah
much better pretty crazy I'm amazed they
let us like use their church I was I was
surprised by that but churches just
seemed to be always the people that let
you hang out where's the church like
anyway stamp
yeah oh and I played Sadie my character
was based on one of the creepy people
from the house from the true story that
were that lost their lives in that house
technically I think maybe I think I died
in another thing outside of the house
but I've been out lived in the house and
then I died and haunted the house and
and I played a twelve-year-old so I
dropped like twenty twenty thirty pounds
I think for that it's really hard and I
love cheese so much like she looks
amazing in that thank you I appreciate
it but yeah so that was that was the
biggest challenge for me was not eating
cheese that's the toughest thing on a
film you're probably doing alright that
okay I hope there was other than that in
crafty that you could at least have
during the crafty had it down am i right
guys I mean we had a variety of like
even gluten-free stuff really underrated
so I'm always happy to chat out the
craft service but you're sick vocals
come in from that were like I'm crafty
service and they would end up like
telling us stories of the house and like
because it was like a very local legend
so they would tell us like you know the
tidbits that they had heard and there
everyone was so excited like sit outside
the house and like watches
does the house have an official name
like if I wanted to google it it goes by
the Frankfort house at least one when we
were googling it about I'll introduce
you to some people who live right near
it who can give you a bit more of the
backstory oh boy
alright this is gonna create a problem
in my life and I'm okay with it before I
have to leave you guys I have a couple
of random questions feel free to shout
out answers pass around the microphones
as you please what TV show would you
guys most want a guest star on American
Horror Story yes
that's my show Atlanta I just want to
work with ice-t
so I'm
it's got to be like a procedural cop
show yeah it's gotta be law and order
what's up what's up t he is great I
worked with him once on one of those
episodes and he was awesome so jealous
Dick Wolf this guy come on my next oh I
was gonna say Game of Thrones I just
want to do a broadsword fight but but
anything that I can do a broadsword
fight that's what I want to do it
doesn't have to be Game of Thrones it
can be like the poor man's team of 2019
chicks don't like - that's a good choice
discovery is in a pretty good place
right now Gambino hit me up Atlanta you
know I'm here you know hopefully you're
here - I would go with Max Headroom
what's the worst job you guys have ever
had I worked I worked at a deli and I
cut the tip of my finger off slicing
roast beef vegetarian now all jobs all
roads have led me here sitting on this
couch doing this interview so I really
like that sir I really can't say that
I've ever had a bad job so to speak I
used to work at a gas station that you
may think was bad but I just have so
many hilarious stories you know chapters
of my life have led me here so I can't
really I can't really [ __ ] on anything
you know there's always a silver a
friend who worked at Amazon and that
sucked
yeah we'll go there we'll go there they
worked in the Amazon
pays us a sponsor anyone else have any
bad jobs I mean I did a student film and
I mean do I have to say anymore I did me
and my little brother when we were
teenagers had to do landscaping on this
random rich woman's yard and we did
everything but landscape we pretty much
screwed up that lady's yard and got paid
a lot of money still so I mean take the
in with the yang what movie do you quote
the most all of them true romance I feel
love I'm loving your I wish my wife was
here so you could ask her this so she
could just cuss a bunch I'm that guy who
I'll have a movie on and I'm just you
know big trouble a little China
slap shot the thing yeah
I'm probably she hates it absolutely I
would say fantastic mr. Fox are you
cussing cussing at me just reference
that one my cousin and I used to always
remember Chris McMillan Velma's wife
actor Chris McMillan right and he goes
by OMA you get your butt back here
Thelma now and he said that to her and
she's like I'm not coming and then she
goes you know you know the movie but
that was like what I said all the time
as a kid we just thought that actor was
hilarious he has many funny lines like
that in the film but that was the one
I'm like like notoriously bad with song
lyrics and movie quotes so every single
time I want to reference a movie I have
to go on IMDB and look at the poll
quotes I mean on the unquote that's what
it's there for it's a good resource so
thank you commenters for updating that
because otherwise I wouldn't be able to
talk film
anything you want to throw in know who
drink all that wine that looks like my
garbage at home I would say that was
here before we got here but who knows
I'll leave that to your imagination
because we're done right now we're done
thank you again to El Tesoro tequila for
helping make this happen so he could
talk about the girl on the third floor
right now guys thank you again for
coming in today huge congratulations on
the movie like and share this interview
as always and keep an eye out for so
much more South by Southwest coverage
coming your way real soon
you